[Music]
[Music]
what a lad now today i'm lucky enough to
be joined by one of the most exciting
and promising young talents in the
country he's recently just turned 18
years old and he's already had three
very impressive games for the mighty
tasman marco he is a kid with a massive
future in the game and like all my
guests ah he is an absolute lad it is
the man with the coolest name in the
game mecca springer welcome mate great
to be here it's been a long time coming
now yeah you said as soon as you had
your debut game you'd be keen to come on
and that came around and then you sort
of wanted a debut start and then you
wanted a shield game so we're finally
here yeah or start off as a bit of a
joke to come on here to be fair and now
we're here so
yeah dreams do come true
but mecca springer that's that is one of
the coolest names in in rugby any story
behind that one um no not really it's
not my that's my bit of a nickname mecca
is it not even your real name nah makai
though mostly no one really knows my
full my full names no when did your
nickname become permanent um
as long as i remember to be fair not
really anyone calls me mecca probably
started at school when all my um
teachers used to call him mckay oh yeah
and i just told him my name was mac and
i make it easier so
just stuck from there but you're happy
with the commentators and stuff call you
mecca yeah yep yeah i am mum and mum
would like them to call me mackay i
don't really care so nah mecca springer
it's got a cool ring to it anyway mate
uh ran philly shield on the weekend
pretty disappointing result but how did
you find it out there um yeah it was
disappointing um
it's pretty cool to get out there and be
a part of such a big occasion though
even
in like 20 minutes was awesome so
a bit unlucky with the result but
yeah it was a pretty cool experience and
first year getting a getting a challenge
so hopefully get a few more in the next
couple years matt you must be pinching
yourself a little bit like just turned
18
you're out there playing for tasman and
iran philly shield game it must must be
pretty buzzy yeah get those give those
um
occasions where i don't really believe
it when i get home and i'm like oh what
did i just what did i just witness and
what i just do but
you know it is pretty cool getting
getting out there and playing with just
names like the big boys that play super
rugby and stuff and getting to know them
is just pretty pretty cool and how do
you find the intensity of a shield match
did you find it to level up to anything
else you've played yeah it definitely
was you could definitely feel a bit more
tension
in the room especially the lead up to it
and the week
going into it so
now it was um definitely a bit more bit
more um
like a bit more tension so the most
intense game you've ever played out of
your three games it was especially being
down when i came on yeah it was a bit
more of a challenge but now it was good
to get out there and
and play even though i did get smoked in
my first touch
but playing fullback how did you find
that because you obviously been training
on the wing most of the season but um
you've had a couple of
cameos at fullback in your time already
yeah now it's good to get i do enjoy
playing fullback a bit more space and
bit more time so that's what i like to
like to play with but um
yeah it is a bit different coming from
wing because i've been playing that
quite a bit lately and i'm quite
familiar with all that stuff so just a
little bit of a change coming into
fullback and
different roles and stuff and trying to
remember them was what i've been trying
to do so yeah do you think you're a
fullback long term or do you see
yourself as more of a winger um yeah
probably in the long term i would like
to be full back instead of wing just as
i feel like as i said before that just
put more space and time and it's just
more my game but um
at this at the moment i'm quite enjoying
wing so we'll see what see what goes so
talk me through the start of the year
for you because obviously you didn't
make the squad initially but then a
couple of injuries and you get called in
um were you expecting it or how was it
when you got that call
um no i wasn't expecting it at all
actually i just
i finished the club season and got to
the um hp stuff and played a few games
with him and i was
pretty happy with that i thought that'd
be my season then play 19s or something
like that so
getting the um call just to be in and
training and stuff was was pretty
awesome at the time just coming in two
days a week and then working the rest
but
yeah
getting the chance to
play was awesome
with a few unfortunate injuries as a
team but um yeah getting getting a shot
to get on the field and play was the
dream from the start so it's pretty cool
and then talk me through the initial
naming of your debut game against
waikato named on the bench did you know
leading up to the team naming that
you're going to be in it that week
no no idea
i thought if i was getting a game i'd be
against
a team not so high caliber is waikato
yeah but um
now it was pretty awesome to get a game
like that
first game so yeah that was
it's great
and on t park in front of i'm guessing
your family came along and all watched
yeah yeah that yeah family came along
mum and dad and my nana and
james lash was old coach from first
fifteen so he came along and um watch
was pretty awesome so yeah i know it was
it was good unfortunately there was no
crowd which would have been made a bit
better but
i was happy to be on t park first game
so what were your nerves like on the
bench because you're a pretty chilled
out relaxed sort of guy usually but what
do you like on the bench um i was good
the whole game actually i was i was good
until
you said jump up mac are you getting on
oh here we go
that's where it started kicking as soon
as i stood up i was like all right
i was gonna do something now
but uh well that was pretty it was
pretty chill
from the morning till
till i was stood up was because i was
fine yeah
yeah you said look out for nervous yawns
that's when i know you know i'm nervous
when you're yawning yeah i didn't see
you yawning too much yeah i do yawn a
lot when i'm nervous
back in verse 15 every time i yawn my
coach is ask if i slept all night nice i
had a great sleep
just yawn every time i'm nervous
but it gets a bit annoying but it's all
right and then talk me through the game
did you feel sweet once you're out on
the field or you're still feeling those
nerves while you're out there as soon as
i got out there
it was all the nerves were gone i was
just getting getting into the game and
feeling it a bit and yeah
so yeah once i was out there it was fine
a couple of first nice touches carry
through fletcher and a couple of big
runs yeah couple
just trying to get smoked first
um yeah no it was good got a ball in
hand and felt a bit more comfortable
after i i had those few touches which
was good
and then the following week southland
you get named to start straight away
you're impressed enough off the bench so
um you've got your opportunity to start
how was that this week leading into this
one
um pretty much the same just
try to go to every training and try and
improve on the stuff i didn't do against
waikato which was
just
just basic stuff but didn't get to do
much in the waikato game but um
leading to southam was pretty cool just
getting to start and getting into the
training runs at the starting position
and stuff was cool so um getting out
there south and i was felt pretty
comfortable after that first game and
got a few touches and got into the game
a bit so it was good so humble what
about the first touch one of the
greatest first touches in history it's
cross kick leaping take beat the
fullback try under the sticks and the
big fins up go on
how did you feel around that one
um i don't know i
wasn't really expecting it came off
really nothing
but uh once i heard the call for the
kick i was got a bit ready and then i
chased it
didn't think i was actually going to
catch the ball
call the ball and then
step the full back after i got past the
footwork i was pretty happy
no
leading up to it
no no i just
did it
[Laughter]
must have settled the nerves after play
like that
yeah no i did helped a lot through the
game so
got a lot a lot of confidence out of it
and then the following week into the
shield game named on the bench were you
expecting the start or
no well i wasn't even expecting to be on
the bench
to be fair
so um yeah
quite a big game so i was just expecting
to be training yeah yeah
pretty exciting to get on the bench and
then stoked to be out there yeah
over the moon to be out there
how good mate we have just got through
your full professional rugby career and
we're 10 minutes in but that is an
awesome start to the podcast but like
all stories
mate we need to know a little bit more
about how you got to become mecca
springer the tasman marco like what was
a young what was life like for a young
macca springer what were you like
um
yeah it's pretty pretty quiet i played a
lot of sports
growing up tennis golf
like everything good at everything
no no not at all what were you good at
uh
golf was off and on as it is now yeah um
uh enjoyed tennis it was all right at
tennis i don't know how big now i'd be
pretty hopeless i'd say
i thought i was good back in the day
and
basketball played a lot of basketball
which i was i wasn't bad at that means
you were good because you're pretty
humble it must have been pretty good no
i was
i was all right yeah
yeah good won the south island did you
so here we go from how we get into it
for wyoming college which is good yeah
yeah shooter or
um
nah not really a shooter just lay up run
run get a ball and then
were you tall for your age growing
growing up no i wasn't very tall was
shorter than all my i wasn't sure
they're always about the same size as
all my mates but um
started putting on a bit of height and
about
year 11. so yeah is this when you grew
your extra vertebrae in your back which
is a true story isn't it it is a true
story i don't know i don't know when
that came
i don't even know what it means
it's there it's not going anywhere
either so
yeah it probably adds a little bit of
height so when did they find that out um
oh
it been a couple months ago now and
everyone oh
just recently right yeah
yeah
bit surprising i did jimmy jimmy holden
told me actually first got back in the
gym before even our physio told i was
pretty surprised what he could tell from
your what squat or no he just walked in
the door and he said you got an extra
vertebra
i don't know how heavy nick's reverted
right but
he seemed he seemed to know
does that cause you any issues to get
back pain or no i've had a bit of back
problems with my disc and stuff but i'm
not sure if that's anything to do with
that but
yeah we'll wait and see something goes
wrong but you can you can do everything
else on it you can squat and do yeah
yeah everything's fine with it no issues
no
and then what about your rugby as a
young fellow obviously you were a bit of
a wizard i've heard rumors that for
under 52. now some bayside you scored 92
points in one tournament which is
ridiculous i think you play about three
games but mate you're obviously an
absolute wizard were you like that from
when you first started
um i can't really remember to be fair
yeah 52's was
most likely to remember from a rugby day
it was only like three years ago
i can't
remember
so you didn't know if you're good or not
no no no idea
when did you first realize that you were
maybe quite good at this game
um probably the 52s when i first i
thought you can remember that i could
remember that that's about the last one
i don't remember so um
yeah probably be 52s and yeah getting
through there and then getting named
mvp of the tournaments was pretty cool
um
then just from there on just
college stuff yeah try to get through
the best i could and then
made the
um crusaders junior nights um camp over
in christchurch which was pretty cool
pretty unbelievable that we're the only
one from waimea to make it there's a few
nelson boys but
yeah and then um
just making it the next year as well
was around really when i thought i'll
give this a crack and
then yeah it's gone from there yeah well
we can't skip over your waimea college
times because that's most of your career
today um how many years were you in the
first 15 with waimea college um i was in
three years but the first year i made it
i wasn't actually allowed to play
because i was too young really yeah so
then i was there's an injured rugby rule
there i was
they changed it like the year before i
actually did it yeah so yeah i wasn't
allowed to play for that first year
since i was too young
and then the next year when i made it
again they changed the rule back to
anyone was allowed to play
so oh here we are and then um
yeah yeah so year 12 and 13 i played as
well yeah which is pretty cool and
for those who don't know why mere
college
they're not a traditional rugby school
but you went on to become the top point
scorer in the uc championship so that's
a huge achievement i don't think you
guys would have even won many games so
how did you manage to do that
um
i'm not really sure to be fair just um
we had a we had actually had a decent
team on our last year of playing so it
was yeah pretty good a few boys they
were pretty good with the ball and
created a lot of space for me because i
was playing full back so it was pretty
good just running off a couple of those
boys and got a few good tries and
yeah how many points did you score on
i'm not sure how many points i scored i
was goal kicking as well but i think i
got 16 tries at last and how many did
the team score seven eight no
no no i didn't even know
you carried they haven't seen it you
carried that side no wonder you got an
extra vertebrae
greatest warmer college athlete since
the great mike coman yeah
was he was he a bit of a
inspiration for you cause he's obviously
it was he the last waimea college person
to sort of come through the rugby ranks
um
yeah
i think so um
yeah i didn't you just
no i'm not sure
i didn't watch a few games when
i was a bit younger you weren't even
born yeah when you went overseas and
stuff that's when i really started
started noticing him and now he's from
waimea which is pretty cool as well
because not many people
come from waimea to play rugby so
yeah and now you get to work under him
so like you're working for the great
komen constructions what a what a
construction company so how have you
found that oh it's been good bit of a
change from the old school stuff
that is good um learning a lot a lot of
new things and
just
yeah
sticking to it do you love it oh i
wouldn't say i love it
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's something to do
once i want to be there my whole life
you hate today i don't hate it you hate
it
after coming in a few days rugby i don't
really wouldn't want to go back to be
fair
[Laughter]
or even the great cayman constructions i
thought you would have wanted to be out
there as much as you could but no
rugby's the dream yeah rugby is the
dream
so when was when did you actually think
rugby is going to be
this could be my career
um probably
just the end of year 13 yeah last year
after i finished that and started i made
the under-20s team for the crusaders
that's when i really thought i'll try to
give this a crack and see how far i can
go with it which is
where i am now so
we'll see how far much further it can
take
and then talk to me about your um
crusader under-20s tournament because
that was obviously the start of this
year um pretty cool opportunity to go up
against the
best players for your age group around
new zealand even though you are still
pretty young to be playing in that side
eh yeah it was it was unreal actually it
was kind of like a little super rugby
tournament for the younger boys that
yeah are coming through which is
awesome like same setup same everything
so it was cool to get out there and play
like it was probably the first time i've
played with on sky sport and it was just
yeah it was awesome staying with the
other boys from all the other teams and
stuff so yeah it's cool who who
impressed you on that competition anyone
or on your side
is there anyone you thought man this
guy's good other than yourself
think about myself
um now there's a few real good boys out
there didn't we i didn't know too many
boys at the time to be fair from other
teams it was quite young all the other
boys knew each other
in the corner
just watching it all go
but um no we there was there's a lot of
talent out there yeah though definitely
but you're not going to give any names
oh nice spoilers i'm thinking of them
luke wrench luca ranch man he came on
and played well yeah he's a good player
isn't he yeah
bit of a character yeah
yeah oh there are definitely a few names
i just think about it no not my head
fair enough and then so from that
tournament and new zealand and the 20s
side was named
and you weren't involved so what was
your feedback you got around that
um well i did get a call from the coach
and just saying that i did play well and
all the rest of that and um just
obviously i said i didn't make it which
i wasn't too wasn't too upset about
since somebody got a couple more years
at it so um yeah it was a bit upsetting
getting the call saying it was so close
and then not actually making the team
but um
yeah i didn't
didn't think about it too much just kind
of gone to the next um his job and so
you you can make that side for the
following two years the next two years
eh yeah i've got two more chances at it
which hopefully get one of them it's
pretty cool it's pretty crazy have you
heard much feedback about around next
year on it
um
a little bit with the
under 20 crusaders stuff yeah starting
oh i think we
kick off in january or something into
january so yeah start their campaign
which will be pretty cool get back into
that
how cool do you think you'll play new
zealand 20s before the all blacks
[Laughter]
so speaking of like sort of future plans
and all blacks and stuff what what are
your goals and plans have you have you
put much thought into it
um a little bit just try to
take every day as it comes to be fair
but um
try mate
uh um super rugby
itc side which is just pre-season with
him which will be pretty cool hopefully
do that in the next year or two and then
just see how far i go with the super
rugby stuff if i make a team and then
not really i don't have much thought
further than that to be fair if i make
the all blacks we'll be awesome but
if i don't do anything don't go anywhere
further i'll probably try to hit
overseas and play some footy and some
other countries and go see something see
something different yeah it should be
pretty
excited about go cash up yeah oh i
wouldn't say kesha
okay something different apart from new
zealand and nelson no fair enough so
what is crusaders the dream is that your
favorite team or
are you proud hurricanes man
um i don't really have a favorite team
yeah
that's a safe option especially when a
lot of teams are circling at the moment
[Laughter]
oh no don't really just yeah
not you because of the hurricanes
but
no i don't support i suppose uh support
the crusaders though you did growing
but no whatever comes
how does itc work
it's just kind of like a pre-season
program
which they pick but i think it's like
five boys from every provincial union or
provincial team and they just train with
the super rugby teams for the start of
the year yeah and then they're mostly
under 20s boys so they they can go on
and play their under 20s competition oh
yeah
um yeah i don't really know too much
about it are you are you able to play
super rugby at the moment if you see
carve up the rest of the
um bunnings cup could you play super
rugby
good question
i'm yeah i'm unsure about that because
there's there is a limit on your game
time at bunning's cup level isn't there
yeah they're only allowed four games i
think so you're already three three
three down so you got one left yeah
you're gonna save it for hopefully a
playoff game or
i don't know i don't think of a choice
it's a bit of a game we get picked for
that's when you last a game for the year
that's pretty crazy eh yeah
well there is a chance though you'll be
able to get for a few more games they
just have to reapply
to the nz rugby and then hopefully they
approve it so i get a few more games but
true
yeah i'm on
yeah
do you have anything to do with that um
approval do you have to speak to anyone
or
no i just got to sign a bit of paper
saying that i'm able to read it yeah
try to do it at the start of the year
oh it's good stuff and obviously your
building career we sort of talked about
it but
um is that what you think you do after
rugby or have you got plans to
i know you're so young but have you ever
put any thought into what you're gonna
do after
rugby
um i had a little a little bit of a
thought just um
probably
try to finish my apprenticeship with
building and then obviously i can do
that anywhere overseas yeah
australia and stuff and make a little
bit more money in here but um i'd like
to own a business some type of business
i'm not sure what yet but what a lad
yeah taking over there
taking over one leg
now what sort of business um
anything yeah boss entrepreneur
so yeah all that clothing brand or
something something cool
you've come to the right place
what about um modeling because one of my
first memories of you
was i was at the richmond races and i
see
a young mecca springer in the fashion in
the fields cleaning up winning the
uh five thousand dollar
clothing voucher for best fashion in the
field just strutting the cat walk like
an absolute legend
talk me through this one
oh
it was a little bit of a piss take to
start with
but i had had a few beers before and i
was like how old were you i was 18.
yeah i was with all my mates i was like
i'll give it there's a crowd just have a
joke you know get up there and do it
so like a few days before i went to sort
my costume out yeah my um suit out
and then got the ass probably the most
nervous i've been
more nervous than the shield yeah
definitely oh just something i just
wouldn't do normally so i was just like
oh here we go
got up bit
the old strut down they can't walk and
then
yeah
got called to the um final made the
final
and then
and then i won it
got on the podium and
got my photo taken
pretty unreal
so good but modelling does come in your
family doesn't it your mum was also miss
nelson i'm pretty sure from from a few
stories i've heard so is that where you
sort of took your confidence to get on
that catwalk bro
no definitely definitely not
um
there's not much restore of why i did it
just
as best
i don't think it's going to happen again
to be fair but um
yeah
mum was a bit she did a bit of modelling
back in the day she's quite young and
yeah that's that's all i've got from it
she doesn't really want me to talk about
it too much because she doesn't like
people know him
right oh well now the whole world knows
oh it's all good stuff so modelling
isn't part of your plans no no you
wouldn't do it no what about if you like
say your career goes really well
jockey come and offer you a pretty
decent contract to be the new dan carter
of new zealand rugby oh
it depends how much
you sound
oh my god
how did he fall for it
saying that rico and akira were coming
back for another
australia are they gonna come back and
do it
i'm not that not that thick man no no
you're a chucky you're a smart smart man
anyway that's that's about your it's
about your career what a career it's
been a small career small but hopefully
this is just the start and
maybe we can get you back on what
allowed in a few
few years sort of document your journey
as you go through all your um future
successes but as always we've gone to
our instagram for some questions and
wow we
we didn't get many for you yeah
no we actually did first question why
didn't you go to nelson college so this
is quite a good question because
obviously nelson college is the nolan
rugby school
in the nelson region but
you decided to stay at waimea college
you bet yourself and look at you now
yeah um no i get this question a lot
but probably the reason i live about a
minute away from the waimea college so
it's a bit easier but easier to get to
and also i just thought if i was going
to make it i'd try and make it in a
small school it's not really it doesn't
change too much for me as long as i
keep going work harder hopefully get
there which i
yeah which i did and made a little bit
from it so
no i don't think it really would have
changed too much if i went to nelson
college i went to to waimea but just all
my mates went to wyoming as well so just
made it a bit better for me enjoyed it
more it's cool what do you think about
all these guys who do go to the big
schools to
try and progress their careers a little
bit earlier um
just optional with whatever you feel to
be fair but um
yeah i wouldn't say not to do it but
you've got the same opportunity as
everyone else if you go to a small
school and make it from there
so you probably get a bit more attention
if you went to a big school yeah as more
people would watch it but um if you do
really want to make it and you do work
hard and
yeah
you will get there it's not like no one
will watch it so yeah yeah and what's
your thoughts on um
sky televising school games
um i think it's pretty cool opportunity
i knew when we um why me had one little
snippet in the sky sport it wasn't
really long but it was pretty cool
experience all the boys were like pretty
excited to just to be on it yeah so no
it is a cool thing called opportunity
for the boys to be shown on sky yeah so
yeah do you think that's why some guys
do go to these schools because they get
that opportunity to get on tv more like
like you say well i mean it probably
didn't have any sky tv games but you
look at nelson college this year i think
they've had three or four so um their
opportunity to get in front of more
people um give them more of an
opportunity or not really
um yeah i'd say it would give you more
of an opportunity as more people would
probably watch it but
yeah just
know if you want to be on sky sport then
go go play for these bigger skills i
guess but we'll just wait a year and
play on the biggest stage for tasmania
yeah
yeah
i didn't think it would be happening
yeah okay next question um who was your
favorite player growing up
oh good question probably like jimmy
marshall
correct good answer
um
ah a few good players i used to watch
bowdoin barrett a lot yeah i liked him
quite a lot so
yeah probably him and geordie which is
the barrett brothers the two barretts
pretty good players so nice like those
couple of absolute lads okay
what happened in the mike sevens final
oh great what's this sorry okay here we
go gene
got this twice actually
must be bad so back in the day he said
um
i don't even know why um i played the
whole tournament
we made the final and
got a bit nervous didn't want to play
the final told my mother started feeling
sick
went home
then the boys played the final they won
the final and now i've just cop [ __ ]
about
not playing the mike's events finals my
whole life so how old were you ah i
don't even know i can't
remember to be fair but
yeah i know what happened
so was this nerves was this just like
full-on bit of anxiety i probably was
nervous and it made me feel sick because
i didn't actually i think i did feel
sick but then i was just like
yeah bit of anxiety going into it and
then
just didn't play boys come through
though got the win for why male boys
so it's good so how have you managed to
obviously if you had that at such a
young age that sort of anxiety and the
nerves around leading up to a game how
have you gone to the complete opposite
yeah
you're not you don't even flinch anymore
so
how have you done that it's probably
them giving me [ __ ]
[Laughter]
just changed my attitude no but um i
don't know what it is it's been just
probably it is probably the attitude
thing it could just change it but more
doesn't mean as much to me like
if i don't play well with if i try my
hardest and don't play well we can't
read too much more yeah
yeah it's probably
not the end of the world you know so
new day that's that's a pretty cool
mindset for someone so young to have
because i mean i remember when i was
your age man i was just i was stressing
about games and you know always wanting
to you think every opportunity sort of
your last opportunity but
you're just comfortable with whatever
happens and back yourself yep just be
myself see where it happens
play good and play good
yeah good set okay next one favorite nrl
player
oh
oh geez
german there oh
[Music]
got to say jaden campbell
oh really young yeah do you know her um
not really my cousin knows him
harrison and um he's sent a question
yeah that's why that's why i knew
straight away but he is no he's pretty
good yeah you've seen him yeah
so yeah is he your age uh no he's he's a
bit old i think he's 21. oh yeah yeah
trying to convert him to teddy oh yeah
true imagine that you and him together
is he trying to would you play league um
i would i think i would
obviously not now yeah and maybe in a
few years if rugby goes
i got wednesday yeah
but yeah and i would i wouldn't i
wouldn't say no to it right now but give
it a shot have you played it before nah
never played did you play touch yeah
played quite a bit of touch in school
years
any good
oh so good okay what do you like most
about rugby
oh
everything apart from hitting rocks and
tackling
nah um
yeah i don't know i just enjoy it
playing with a new bunch of mates every
year so it's pretty cool pretty cool to
get out there and just play something
that you love which is what i do what do
you love about it
oh
what's not their love about it i don't
know
i thought it would be a tough question
but kicking
running and kick just not hitting rocks
that's the one thing i
wouldn't love about it okay we got this
one a few times actually is he single
yeah
hey wow now we actually got it once but
that's right um it's pretty right
exciting times yeah
it's not that exciting
just don't need don't need a girlfriend
here too young man
are you are you looking or now you're
pretty keen to stay single first single
yeah yeah yeah for life or see so just
work on the old rugby stuff first of all
yeah maybe settle down
later later on
man you've got your life all mapped out
i love it okay this must be a personal
story why didn't you want to get nude in
front of chris at a court session
well this is obvious why would you get
your name
who's chris oh
a guy that played for a um senior a team
oh yeah so apparently he's seen
everyone's penis apart from mine yeah
so the whole court session he was
telling me to get my [ __ ] out oh just
made it you make it awkward when you're
saying to someone to get your [ __ ] out
so it would have been fine if he just
didn't keep saying it but he kept saying
it and then all the boys got behind him
and
we could get your [ __ ] out so i was like
that's enough i'm leaving
oh fair enough geez good stuff okay how
does first 15 team you face
[Music]
in what year
first year combat experience you name it
probably would have been christchurch
boys
or nelson college in our first year
which they had a pretty good team they
won the comp and then went up north so
yeah probably nelson college in our
first year we played them i think it was
like
oh 92 12 or something
and you got the 12 points
yeah did you
oh was it okay
player you'd least like to tackle
you got to say
jim the brass at the moment oh you
really wanna no one would want to tackle
them have a levi mower yeah not someone
you would want to stand in front of it
anytime soon so
a couple of good shouts what about
internationally
oh
i don't even know
probably who's that prop from aussie oh
what's his name daniela tupol yep nah
wouldn't take a whim i would try
i wouldn't tackle
okay
we sort of talked about this one but um
what's your lifelong goal in rugby
um it would be to make the all blacks
but um just at this at this point in
time probably might try to make a super
team and then what i see before try go
overseas if nothing else works out with
the all blacks but
yeah just hit overseas and get a new
experience somewhere else
would you would you go overseas early
looking to come back are you pretty keen
to see how far you can get in new
zealand and then the more traditional
way we start looking overseas once
you've gone as far as you can here um
i'll probably just
see how far i can get here first and
then hit overseas
which is probably my main goal and then
probably
retire after that which would hopefully
be a few more years away yeah another 15
at least
okay next question what is your most
embarrassing moment in your life
ah
probably um we had a old family
it was a party over-enabled tasman yeah
went over there not wanting to drink
this is when i was actually 18. yeah so
i went over there not wanting to drink i
was being sober driver
turns out there's free beers so i was
i'll get into it again
got pretty pretty drunk i can't remember
anything of the night but apparently i
told my
these videos of me telling my family
all my sexual intercourses but i don't
remember at all
but yeah my sister's got videos of me
telling my mum
i think that's when my mum found out and
then
yeah that's
when i
went on the boat back
yeah it wasn't great
that's not good i need to see these
videos
they're not crazy at all
but yeah probably that's probably the
one i remember there'd be a few more
embarrassing stories
it's pretty hard to top that's a lot of
um experiences too
you're telling your mum yeah something
you don't really want to be telling your
family no
but yeah
fair enough hell
that is a good story
okay next one favorite cartoon show
growing up
um
i quite enjoyed phineas and ferb
you know that
you're kidding yeah what is that oh it's
hard to explain it's just weird
characters and they build
they like make
like different inventions
and then they'd use them and then their
sister finds out and then goes to tell
their mum
and then
the invention's gone
[Laughter]
they're in spongebob
is it still on
i don't know can't say i watch disney
channel anymore as it wasn't on disney
channel it was yeah okay or cartoon i'll
look it up on youtube so yeah give it a
watch highly recommend i wouldn't say at
the time you highly recommend
right now how old were you i know you
hate this question you never know how
old you are
how old were you
i would have been about four or five
so about 2 000 and what nine or
something geez it's good stuff
okay
last question
best piece of advice you've received so
you've obviously had done a lot in your
career today so what advice have you got
that stands out for you to get you this
far this early um probably just be
yourself you know come into the
environments and
people obviously act a bit different in
the
than they are but um probably just be
yourself and come in and
just
be who you are and if people like you
for who you are then that's all you can
ask for
so yeah probably that too fair stuck
with me for a bit mate that you are wise
beyond your years that is incredible
advice for an 18 year old kid to be
giving out that advice that that's
special are you you are this is
genuinely who you are isn't it yeah this
character here yeah no yeah it wouldn't
be acting for you here no he's a very
chilled out man great kid and massive
future in the game so mecca i really
appreciate you coming on the podcast i
know
when you first mentioned it you were
kind of joking but i was really keen to
get you on because
um i think you've got a massive future
in the game and i'm looking forward to
following it and i'm sure a lot of the
listeners who have listened to this
episode will enjoy following your career
from now on as well so mate really
appreciate coming on the podcast and
giving up your time thanks mate
appreciate it it's been good until next
time until next time that's uh
lad